hi I'm just I'm looking for a check  mm-hmm who's asking John chef jr. do  your son my son jr. yeah  you know they say that cat shed is a bad  mother shut up now ignore him  thinks he's a black James Bond that dude  was real you think it was me  [Music]  investigation I want to babysit your ass  [Music]  never long enough lady syphilis  madam chlamydia it's lovely to meet you  both that's doing it well see a little  bitter please tell me that you did not  get out son involved in your [ __ ]  picked up a bet you can't beat up a  woman  why not because she's a woman that's  misogynistic you won't be misogynistic  I ain't mention agenda okay I'm an  equal-opportunity asked what  [Music]  right Sarge you okay yeah  [Music]  but back in the day we didn't need guns  all we needed was our bare-knuckle tale  grandpa oh you can't be too prepared  let me get my key back it having an  iPhone oh hell do I shut it  damn right what's up  [Music]  [Music]  you